Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live.
I'm your host Rawkode.
Today is clustered,
but slightly different. Today is clustered newcomers edition.
We, I have broken a Kubernetes cluster in
a few ways to aim and hopefully provide
a journey for people that aren't as
long in the tooth and the Kubernetes landscape.
They wanna understand some of the more primitive
aspects,
basics,
I don't know a whole bunch of other
stuff. It's really hard to break a cluster
when the people have no idea. So we're
gonna see how it goes. Now before we
get started, I wanna encourage you all to
please subscribe to the YouTube channel, click the
bell. This will get you notifications for all
future episodes of Rawkode live and clustered.
And, of course, if you wanna talk about
cloud native Kubernetes and anything in between, please
join us in the Discord server.
Alright. Now joining me today, I have Jeremy,
Jason, and Tom, three wonderful
colleagues from Equinix. Hello, all. How are you
doing?
Hey. Go. Hi, Charles. Great.
Today? Excellent.
Awesome.
Why don't we just do a quick round
of introductions, get to know everybody, and then
we'll get started for today.
I pass the baton to you, Jeremy.
Excellent.
I am Penguin, Jeremy to my mother-in-law.
I am David's teammate at Equinix Medal,
and I'm looking forward to,
he said, pretend you know nothing about Kubernetes.
And so this is not this is not
method acting.
It's this should be a this should be
a real easy one.
Oh, I suppose a quick question. Should I
also be in the discord, or is that
where you'll be taunting us off screen?
You do not have to be on the
Discord. No. It's all good. Everything will come
through the YouTube comments, and my laughter comes
in all places. Very good.
Perfect.
Yes. And I'm Jason.
Also,
of these fine gentlemen at Equinix Metal.
I've been active in the operational life cycle
management space in Kubernetes since 2015,
and I'm looking forward to help walking
Tom and Jeremy through fixing this cluster.
And I am Tom Crow. I also work
here on the developer
relations advocacy team.
And, I
wear as a badge of honor or shame
depending on where you are that I have
never been able to keep a Kubernetes cluster
up and running. So,
I have a lot of experience on the
working with broken clusters,
very little experience fixing them. So I'm looking
forward to what we can do today. Is
there such a thing as a working Kubernetes
cluster? I'm not entirely sure.
That's
that's my white whale.
Alright. Well, I wanna say thank you all
for joining me today. I know this was
a little bit short notice, but I really
appreciate this and I think this will be
a whole lot of fun. So
we're gonna start by popping over my screen
share. We have teleport as we always use
on clusters. We have just the one cluster
that is broken. My
involvement today will merely be to click the
connect button,
which I think I do rather finely.
I will zoom in on the phone and
if you could all do me a favor,
join this active session,
give me an echo hello, not all at
once. Well, I guess you can go for
it if you want. I see one connection
so far.
Let's get two more.
There we go. Thank you. Four connections.
I've never noticed this on teleport before, but
it has this lovely little number at the
top left, and then you can hover it
to see the name.
Cool.
Yeah.
Wow.
There we go. Right.
We have hopefully a still broken cluster.
Fifty fifty at this point, I think. But
I am not gonna say any more just
now. I'll let Jason
share his thoughts and insights with you both.
And Jeremy and Tom, best of luck.
Yeah. So from the spot that we're in
right now, I think we have one of
two options. One of them is is we
can try to
access the application deployed on the cluster and
see where things are from that state. Or
since we're already at the command line,
we can do a little inspection with kubectl
and see what the state of the control
plane is and try to see if
we at least get a response back that
way.
Yeah. How would we check on if the
I was voting option one, but alright.
Yeah. So our what is our desired state?
What what should we be seeing if the
application was working?
So, ideally,
I believe that we're looking at a WordPress
application,
normally deployed on these clusters.
Although,
generally,
I don't think we actually expose it out
to the Internet. So you you would actually
have to proxy things through. So we probably
need to start with the control plane anyway
and see where things are there since
kubectl proxy is probably not gonna work for
us if our API server is not up
already.
Okay.
So probably the easiest place to start is
we can do something like kubectl version,
which should,
if the API server is up,
actually tell us what version of the server
we're connected to.
And, actually, in this case,
we are going to have to
set the cube config either through the environment
variable or the command line flag to connect
to it.
So in this case, if doing the environment
variable,
it should be kubeconfig,
all capital letters,
no spaces.
And then we can do
set it to etsy kubernetes
admin dot conf, I think, is the default
one by
no. The default admin config.
Yep.
That's right.
I think that's true for all Kubernetes clusters.
Right?
Yes.
Oh,
you didn't actually export
that environment variable.
I was gonna say, I'd be a little
surprised if Micaiah started to wrap up. Already?
For for times like this where we have
to go back and redo things, David, it'd
be nice if we had some circus music.
I'll work it back in?
Nope. Yeah. I think it's supposed to be
just conf, not config. Oh, admin dot conf.
Yeah.
Ah, there we go. Okay. So we did
get a response back from the server,
and we can see that the server is
running version one dot 20 dot four. It
matches our client version, which is what I
would expect on a Kubernetes based cluster.
Now
we can do
you know, basically, we can start with just
looking to see what the state of pods
are in the cluster.
So if you did, like, a get pods
dash capital a,
that'll
or kubectl get pods dash capital a.
That
should tell us, you know, what the current
status is of the pods across
all namespaces.
And
it looks like most everything is running except
for
that one pod in the default namespace.
So what we can do here is we
can actually do a kubectl describe on that
pod, and that will give us additional information
whether it's events that have been generated for
that pod or the status of the pod.
It'll give us a nice summary of
where things sit there.
You'll have to do a dash in to
set the namespace there.
I think Tom was riding on top of
me.
Sorry.
Jeremy.
Let's do this Passion. Pair programming styles. So
Jeremy, you take just now and I'll yell
switch, and then we'll have a talk to
you over for a bit.
There we go.
Alright. And you now actually have to tell
it the resource that we want. So you
wanna tell it a pod,
and it doesn't matter what order you
put the flags in with everything else. This
is actually gonna give you all of the
pods,
but there's only that one pod in that
namespace. So it
works effectively the same.
Okay.
We got
wait.
Alright.
So we can see here that it could
not actually create the pod sandbox for this.
And we're seeing a
connection reset by peer. So that's that's a
fun one.
The other thing we can see,
we can see some various other information here.
If we scroll up a little bit,
we can see that there are no node
selectors involved that we're dealing with here.
Is it one
port off? Should
eighty eighty and 8081 be the or different?
Where are you seeing that? Where yeah. Where's
8081, Jeremy? Oh, up there. It says port
eighty eighty one TCP,
but the
readiness is showing Liveness and readiness below are
looking at Eighty eighty. 80 80.
Yep. So I think that you have something
there.
Now we just gotta figure out which one
of the two is incorrect.
So let's talk about that. Right?
Are you gonna say something, Tom?
Well, I'm seeing up here as I went
up higher, it's saying the connection to the
server eighty eighty was refused. You specify the
right host report?
Okay. But just thinking out loud. Okay.
So what were you gonna say, David?
Yeah. I think it was a keen eye
spot in the 8081 and the 8080.
But,
Jason, would that cause a container not to
start?
I wouldn't necessarily expect that to cause the
container not to start. I would expect that
to,
cause more issues with,
after the container's already started,
because the liveness and readiness probes don't kick
in until after the pod has been created.
Alright. So what are our likely candidates? So
if we have a
unable to create sandbox or container not starting,
what are the go to things we should
be checking?
Well,
probably the first thing, we'd probably wanna see
what node this is assigned to so that
we can go ahead and inspect things on
that node.
Obviously,
you might wanna check to see if container
d is actually
running.
And if there are if it is, are
there any errors in there or in the
cubelet logs trying to
connect to container d on that server?
Okay.
So Jeremy, Tom, do you know how to
check which node part was scheduled on?
Nope. Where's that?
So
one of the places that I would probably
look is if you actually do kubectl describe
on the nodes, it'll show you what pods
are scheduled
on all of those nodes.
You know what? I didn't know that.
I
had no idea you could describe a node
and get a list of pods. That's awesome.
This looks like ours.
Yep.
There we go. That's it.
So what's the node name for that node?
It is VVXCW.
Yes.
Yep. So we should probably switch over to
a teleport session on that node.
I have made it. So
DVXCW.
Okay. Here we go. We're in.
I think Tom oh, there we go. Alright.
I had to do a weird reload, but
we're we're back.
Alright. So probably first thing first, we can
check to see if container d is actually
running on this host or not.
You know, you can do that either through,
like, p s or
system d commands to check the status of
the service.
So p s on its own will actually
only list a few processes. You'll wanted to
add some selectors to it. I tend to
use p s a u x to list
all processes.
There we go.
Alright. So we can see container d is
actually running.
Running. Yeah.
And we know the cubelet's running from
knowing that, you know, there's a node resource
there and it at least tried to schedule
it on this host.
So we can take a look at
either the kubelet logs first or the container
d logs and and try to see if
there's anything in either of those saying why
we're not seeing a running container.
Let's
look at the container d logs. Where are
those found?
Alright. So we should be able to use
journal cuddle
dash u. I think it's just container d,
the service.
And
then probably give it a dash l too
to make sure that
we get the full line length.
You'll need to add a dash dash no
pager.
Or I think you can do
l f.
I can't remember.
Go
for it. Yeah. Try l f.
No. The dash l f. Sorry. Yep.
Just an add an f to the l.
Yep. There you go. Yep.
Oh,
failed to create container tasks.
What are we getting here?
Just
so that I feel less guilty, I did
think the error message on this one would
be a lot more explicit.
OCI runtime
created failed.
It
doesn't look like container d is gonna give
you much. I would maybe try JSON's suggestion.
Kubelet logs would be where?
It'll be the pretty much the same journal
coddle command except instead of container d, we
want Kuplet.
Alright. Only I'll switch now.
Okay.
RPC.
Alright. I think I'll throw a hand in
because the header message isn't what I expected
it to be here.
I
only modified
the deployment resource. So you can do this
all from the control plane by taking a
look at the YAML.
Yeah. That that's where I was gonna head
next
because as far as the kubelet and container
d, they're not really giving us much.
Yeah. I'm surprised by that, to be honest.
I should have checked it, but I I
I thought it would have been okay.
Yeah. Yeah. So I'll I'll jump back over.
You can close this tab. Think it's safe
to say we'll we'll work from the control
plane.
Yeah. Okay.
There you go. Alright. So let's go ahead
and do a describe on the full deployment
for that. So if we do a kubectl
get deployments,
let's see what that deployment is called so
that we can go ahead and describe it.
We're doing a kubectl. What was that?
Get deployment? Get deployments.
Oh, easy enough.
Deployment singular. It helps if you spell it
right. I quite like deployments.
Alright. And so we can just do a
describe on that cluster deployment. So kubectl describe
deployment
clustered.
With a k. Yep. Yep. I see that.
Got it.
Alright. Nobody can take the nerve and watch.
That is the rule. It's a lot more
nerve wracking to tell you why, you know,
you're live. This is insane.
Are you on a nonstandard keyboard, Tom? I'm
on a standard keyboard. That's what makes it
worse. I hear you on your mechanical keyboard,
so you have an excuse, Jeremy.
Where are we here?
Okay.
Now,
live link is ready. Yeah. So you should
probably just go through this top to bottom
and look for anything in over there. Ordinary.
Okay. So we've got
There's
default. Is that correct the correct URL for
GitHub Container Registry there? Yeah. Yeah. That that
that's all good.
The next thing is we can take a
look at the port configurations.
There's one in there that's kinda standing out
to me. It's a little bit odd just
looking at it.
The liveness and readiness
URLs have no
have no IP associated with them.
Just a just a port.
Yeah. There there's also some else that's standing
out as a little bit odd to me
too as far as
some of that container configuration.
What's that?
Host port zero?
Yeah.
Zero TCP.
Yeah. Host port zero is
okay.
We're not actually exposing the host port. That's
just what that looks like.
Okay.
What is
GHCR
radio?
That said, I do think
y'all were on to something with the
the port configuration and the liveness and readiness
probes not matching up.
So we probably need to bring those back
into alignment.
Yeah. So I've spoken to the developer,
and he expects the application to run on
port eighty eighty. Just
put that there.
Okay. So we need to change
this the eighty eighty one to eighty eighty?
So Noah was also asked in the comments
about the no IP in the probes.
Yeah. This is just standard convention on liveness
and readiness probes. The IP can be embedded
that runs
against the pod itself, so will know the
port as necessary. The output always throws me
as well. It's weird, but it is okay.
Okay. So we wanna edit this thing in
place. We can do kubectl edit,
and that'll let us drop us into an
editor
to make changes to the resource. You wanna
tell it what resource, so in this case,
a deployment,
and the name of the resource.
So in this case, clustered.
Clustered.
I think with an e. Yeah. There we
go.
K. 8880.
Looks good. Scroll down. Either that or you
can search for 8081.
Yep.
I'm not seeing 8081.
You hit the bottom? You can search in
Vim by pushing forward slash and then type
in your search term.
Oh, I I see what I've done.
Yep. There you go. Classic table. Yep. There
we go.
Where did it go? Here it goes.
There it is. Yep.
Line 51, I think. Yep.
Shift and a to add to that line.
Shift.
And then push one and then hit escape.
Yeah. Sorry. Vem is the default editor. If
you've not used it before, it is a
pain in the ass.
So just type one zero and then escape
and then colon w q.
Yeah. Sorry about that, Tom.
No worries.
How many how many ways are there to
enter into There
are probably I don't know. I use four
or five regularly, but I'm sure there's many,
many more. But shift a to stay in
the current line, j to jump down the
next line. There's a whole bunch more.
Or I. I think so. But that's booting.
That
took okay. So if we we fixed that.
Alright.
So we can go ahead and take a
look at those pods again to see if
that pod
does finish coming up. Because right now,
the state of that deployment is showing one
desired, one updated, two total, and
two unavailable still.
That would be too harsh, Kevin.
What is it? He said, don't tell anyone
how to explain them.
I haven't touched them at all in a
in a minute. Let's see. Good Throw the
throw the whole throw the whole computer away.
Did you run it get pods?
I think he ran the deployment again. Yeah.
I did. Describe on the deployment.
Hello.
Get pods.
Alright. And we still see it's container So
we'll wanna hit go ahead and do another
describe
on that second instance there, the one with
the age of seventy five seconds.
This one here?
It doesn't show me your cursor, so we
want the second one of the two. Yep.
44 v 22? Okay. You need to describe
pods. Just the last part. Yep. And I
need pods. Yep. Describe
pods.
Delete space.
You need the whole name. There you go.
Need a space.
Okay. This is nerve racking.
It's alright. You can swap back in in
a minute.
If
you have not done this on Rawkode Live,
I recommend I recommend it. That's a lot
of fun.
Almost a decent year.
Alright. And we're still seeing the same issue
there.
Yeah.
However, one of the things that I'm thinking
of is as we're setting up the pod
sandbox,
we need to interact with
another pluggable component of the cluster
to kinda make that pod sandbox,
and that's gonna be
whatever CNI is deployed.
I have not touched the CNI.
You have not touched the CNI. So that
was good. It's it's really
you'll kick yourself, Jason. It's staring you in
the face.
Alright. I I would like to phone a
friend. Audience watching. Give us a hint if
you see that. I don't think the audio
like, the audience are normally pretty quick to
to phone in what they think it is,
and no one has mentioned this yet. I'm
really, really surprised.
But in the interest of time, do you
want me to get throw something out there?
Is that your way of saying that not
only are your guests, but your audience is
also disappointing you greatly on this one, David?
Yeah. Exactly.
Yeah. Can can you throw us a bone?
Alright. I've highlighted the oh, you might not
be able to see the screen share.
Yeah. I see the share.
Limits c m. C p five.
Oh,
yes.
So I really expected the error message to
complain
about the limits. But
Yeah. That was disappointing. So we we probably
want more than one Mibi byte of memory
for our pod.
I have so much respect for you for
actually calling it a Mibi byte and not,
you know,
maxing up SI and non SI standards.
Alright. So we probably wanna go in and
re edit that deployment and increase
that memory count a little bit.
What's the the full deployment here?
After
this command, it's swoppy time again.
Nope.
The deployment's just called clustered. That's the the
pod. Yeah. Yep. That's the pod. I'm not
going to do the full thing. And, Jeremy,
you're up.
Alright.
We are going back down to two Mibi
bytes.
We'll just keep adding a Mibi byte until
it works.
So should we talk about resource requests and
limits where we get the quick TDLDR
on that?
Yeah. What do you what do need to
get a Kubernetes cluster up and running? What
what should we have here as a minimum?
So that's
highly gonna depend on your application.
And
underneath the resources, have
two different
kind of
types of resource limits that you you have
the limits and then you have the requests.
Mhmm. The requests are used to make scheduling
decisions to say, you know, where should I
schedule this pod
based on how much memory
I'm gonna request from it. Limits actually put
actual kinda guard barriers. It will not let
the application use anymore.
It'll define some c groups on the host
and limit the amount of memory that you
have specifically to what you set in the
limits.
So this is what'll keep me from so
this is what'll keep me from deploying a
a 300 gigabyte
server somewhere for
my my cluster. Right?
Yeah. Exactly. This is what allows you to
basically define,
you know, how much over provisioning you want
in your cluster and Mhmm.
You know, avoid, you know, too much over
provisioning for those applications.
And generally for Kubernetes clusters,
you disable swap on the host. So
when things do actually run out of physical
memory on the host,
you're looking specifically at oom kills rather than
thrashing swap
when those things go bad. So you really
wanna make sure that when you're defining your
applications,
you want to try to match
your request and limits
closely to what, you know, the application generally
uses.
And you can you know, if sometimes it'll
surge a little bit, you can set the
limits a little bit higher than the requests,
that sort of thing.
In this case, we're talking about a WordPress
application, I or is this a WordPress application
or is this something else? Yeah. It's just
a small rust binary. I mean, we could
either remove the limits altogether or you can
throw it up to, you know, one CPU
and a hundred mega RAM or something like
That's probably over provisioning,
but
they also don't need to be set.
You can set that to 500 or 1,000
whenever you fancy.
And the way to work this out as
a question I think we all probably get
a lot is, oh, how do I set
them as this continuous profile, good metrics, all
of that. Just really really start to understand
your application
under multiple scenarios to low load, high load,
etcetera.
Yep. And there's things like the
vertical
autoscaler that you can use
to get a baseline for what your application
uses. It'll automatically
increase those limits for you
as
use kind of increases on the application.
We're running.
David, did we do the thing?
I'll be honest. I did not expect that
to be running after that.
So clearly,
one of the other breaks has not really
panned out, but that's okay. But if you
can do a get pods on the cube
system namespace, we can maybe take a look
at what should have happened.
There are more things to fix, don't worry.
Kube cuddle. Nope. Kube cuddle.
And I can see the chat.
Oh, this isn't my turn anyway. This is
your turn, Jeremy. Sorry.
To follow-up on the profiling discussion, Noel in
the chat is mentioning that there was a
talk at KubeCon talking about using the VPA
to profile applications.
Nice.
Yep. There we go. Oh, okay.
Which namespace am I? In kube system namespace,
please. Kube dash system. That's where all of
the Kubernetes control plane stuff runs.
I think I'm about to learn something else
today that I didn't know. Yeah.
You see anything weird here?
Our scheduler is not
happy right now. But we did get a
scheduled pod.
We did. It's running, but it's not ready.
Yes.
So,
we can go ahead and, do a describe
on that, and see
what's going on there.
And then in this case, we'll also have
to specify the namespace like we did above,
so dash n cube dash system.
And then you'll probably wanna copy and paste
because I we haven't configured
tab completion on this host.
So I do have a question. If the
scheduler is not working, why how did it
schedule?
So I didn't expect the scheduler to really
respond to any requests
because it wouldn't end up in a service
endpoint, but that was really naive of me
and I now understand that that's stupid because
it's a controller that's actually listening to the
Kubernetes API server. So
the thing I did
is merely amusing at best, but completely pointless
and clustered at worst.
Because there's only one schedule.
Anyway, it doesn't matter.
You you can fix it or not fix
it. It's up to you. It may be
interesting to look at what I changed.
Alright. Describe
Let me just scroll up, scroll down. Like
Let's go up.
So and because it's showing that it's not
ready, that tells us that the,
readiness probe
is not firing.
And if we look at the
liveness
probe definition there,
we can see that there are indeed failures.
And we can also compare the
actual
command line used for it to that
to that probe configuration.
And if I jump out at you, Jeremy,
or Tom?
Not just yet.
So there's a flag at the end of
the defined command there that is standing out
to me.
I sense failure.
So if we're looking just a little bit
up of where
Makai has highlighted on his screen,
we see the tail end of command line
arguments there.
Is that a little bit more? So
you've got port zero there, but also,
port
ten
one twos,
one zero two five nine
as
the
for liveness and startup.
Yeah. Yeah.
I haven't I haven't modified ports.
Okay. Not out of.
Yeah. That port zero is another thing that
always confuses me on clustered, but preferably legal.
Oh, yes. That's probably
is that disabling the
HTTP endpoint for it?
I don't recall, but let's say that sounds
like a pretty good shit.
Again, it's it's it's it's simpler
than user thinking about it.
Anyone in chat see the
see the thing?
Oh, you're gonna kick yourselves again.
Hold hold on. I'm not It is a
it's a pressure, though. Do you know you
got people watching you and you're looking at
it, like
but
I I I promise you, I have kept
all of these
superficial
breaks.
You see any difference between the liveness probe
and the startup probe?
Oh, there's a nice long delay in there.
That fifty to thousand second delay.
You know how many hours fifty thousand seconds
is?
Thirteen.
Okay. That felt too obvious though.
I I have kept I have kept the
the break simple and I love the one
that's just showing. It's like even the simple
things are so easy to overlook when you're
trying to fix something because
but yeah, there you go. So
how how do we fix
the scheduler, Jason? What's different about that to
other workloads on the cluster?
So,
obviously,
what we're looking at here is the static
pod
mirror manifest. So the control plane components on
a Kubernetes based cluster
are deployed via static manifest. And
if we actually try to edit them through
the API, they would not actually have any
effect.
So we'd actually wanna look on disk at
the configuration here,
and
that's basically gonna be in the Etsy Kubernetes
manifest directory
by default. So assuming that
Micaiah has an thrown us a curveball and
modified
where the manifests are, that's where we wanna
look for the kube scheduler manifests scheduler configuration
there.
I have not done that. I
promise. Yeah. So a lot of the comments
there are were pointing to the Port Zito
as well, but that is a a red
herring.
And that's one of the fun things
because Kubernetes
now is
let's see. It's 2021,
originally started in 2014,
the project.
So we have a little bit of legacy
now. So every once in a while, there
are a lot of command line flags that
need to be set in kind of awkward
ways to
kind of deal with that legacy. So you
do end up with some of those
things that look weird but are actually perfectly
fine.
Yep.
And it's only through trial, editor, and experience
that you actually pack up in a lot
of those. Like, even prior to clustered, I
had no idea about all these random port
zeros and stuff. Yeah. Nor nor should you.
I was gonna use Vom to edit it
to see if that was it jumped right
to the place. So I assumed that that
was the That's cool. Vim has
been useful for that before on clustered, I
gotta say.
I assume
there's a way to erase your most recent
most recent edited line. Yeah.
I'm sure there's probably some Vim cache fail.
I could
blow away, but yeah. You can save that
five ten and it's all good. Just save
it and then I should get.
There you go. One bug fixed.
Get pods as your your nother star here.
I'd keep focusing on that. Yeah.
So that should be on. You should see
that go to ready and
what so the delay to ten seconds. Yeah.
Just let it open seconds.
And so you can actually do a get
pods add a dash w to the end
of that. That would actually watch the event.
Watching it? Yeah.
It depends on how many I think it
was three. So when I guess to thirty
seconds, we should see a one on one.
And after this is healthy, we'll swap back
to Tom, please.
No. Thank you.
Noel is enjoying it. The simple things that
get overlooked.
Yeah. Definitely. It's it's easy to overlook the
simple things.
One scheduler.
We don't have to wait on it as
as we found out the break doesn't even
work anyway because the scheduler continues to act
as a scheduler even when it's not ready.
So we we can just get pods and
move on just now.
No. There are no honks or rec rolls.
I was there.
Let's take it easy on this one.
Alright.
Thanks for listening. We
look like we're running. Right?
Do we wanna go ahead and run that
again for all namespaces
and see where everything else is sitting to?
So get pods dash capital a? Yep. Yep.
Everything is running.
Everything is running. Everything is ready. Yep. Mhmm.
Do you want me to try a port
forward from my local machine?
Yeah. Let's give that a shot and check
on the status of that application.
Newcomers.
Export.
K. Get pods.
He's a little faster than we are, Jeremy.
Well, it's it's it's that auto completing there.
Exactly.
Alright. So our application. Uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
But we fixed the thing.
You fixed one thing.
Could you tell your browser could you tell
your browser that it should be working and
ask to try hard try harder?
It's a part of a horror movie where
everyone's dancing around the fire celebrating while an
emergency emerges
from the lake and creeps up onto the
dock. Khalid thinks it seems fine.
My browser doesn't seem to think it's fine.
If we pop over
we're not getting any error messages. So we
are getting successfully a request to our cluster
pod. However,
it would seem that we are not getting
a response from our cluster pod.
I'm not sure what the timeout is supposed
to be here. You will see a connection
to a database timing out when it eventually
lands.
And you are talking directly to the pod
here, so we don't have to look too
deeply into things like
the service networking and and that sort of
thing. So we can definitely just start looking
directly at
the pod.
If we're expecting it to talk to a
database,
we probably wanna figure out where that database
is supposed to be
so that we can, you know, actually talk
to it. One of the things standing out
to me is that I didn't see any
pods related to a database.
David, are we supposed to have a database?
I have a drone. Keep control
something something.
I mean, how does this speak to a
database?
That's that's not a command, David.
So I'm gonna have to tweak the time
out on my Rust application. Really, you should
have an error message right now saying it's
trying to speak to something called Postgres.
So there's your queue. There's your queue.
Okay.
So one of the things we can look
at here is we can look at,
you know, what types of resources would we
use to even deploy a database. So we
can look to see if there's any stateful
sets to find in the cluster.
So just like a kubectl get
stateful set.
Postgres is not ready.
Yeah.
So we can do the same thing that
we did with the previous ones. We can
run describe on there and see what type
of data it gives us there.
And you'll need to tell it what you
wanna describe. So in this case, a stateful
set.
Stateful
Okay.
Alright. And
one of the things that I noticed is
it wasn't even trying to
deploy a pod here. Otherwise, we would have
seen
that when we were doing the pod output.
So
if we look at the configuration
of this,
you know, there's some that stands out to
me
immediately
that
explains why we weren't seeing any type of
pod creation.
Yeah. Please don't write down my password. I
use this for everything. I was gonna say
besides besides the terribly weak password?
It seems that we've desired zero replicas,
which seems like exactly what we've got.
Yes. Yep.
What we can do is we can
Database list.
We we can actually use the kubectl scale
command here to go ahead and change that.
Alternatively, you could just do an edit
on that resource and change it like we
did before. But since
since stateful sets exposed the scale subresource,
we can just do kubectl
scale.
We're gonna
and and if you just hit enter there,
it'll help guide us through what we need
to do.
So
let actually, do kubectl scale dash dash help,
and that'll give us
and I think in this case, we just
tell it what we want to scale.
Yep. So
we'll wanna specify that dash dash replicas,
and we probably don't wanna go higher than
one here. I don't know if this
There's there's no PVCs being used. All the
data is loaded through and then a container.
You can scale it to whatever you wish.
It'll it'll be fine.
Yep.
Replicas, however many,
Three ten whatever stateful set slash.
And that says swap your time again, please.
Anything else? We good?
You know,
Postgres
q l.
No space and probably singular instead of
Big reset?
Yep. Slash.
So you can use the singular, the plural,
or the short versions across all of these
commands as well. Okay.
But yeah.
Best to pick one and stick to it.
There's an extra e in there, looks like.
Oh, there it is. Post
egress.
Failed.
Alright.
So
we
take a look at those.
Take a look at that again, we should
see it's created a pod.
Yep. There we go. Create pod, stateful. Successful.
And
now we're just waiting to see if the
liveness and readiness probes
finish up.
It'd probably run a git pods or something.
Yeah.
Great tip, whoever's typing, but control r and
then type part of a command will
bring it front and center for you.
Alright. So it looks like those Postgres pods
are in a good state now, so we
can
potentially go back and try that application again.
And, David, that'll be hitting command r. We'll
do that for you? No. So if you
do Oh, control. Control r
and then type pods.
There you go.
And then hit return, you get your command.
So that's Oh. Still timing out. I meant
Nope. But so it's not gonna work if
you refresh.
So we got
well, look at your custard pod.
Up at the top there,
MGTPW
Right here. That one's not restarting. Unready restarted
five times.
Yep.
So
one of the things we can do here
is we can actually look at the logs
for that clustered pod and see I'm really
sorry. There there's no logout. There's
no logout.
Just because it's it's a really simple application.
I have to terrible Who built this application?
You'll wanna just I would just dive through
We can only do we
can only do so much with what we're
given here, David.
Just just do a see, we've done a
lot of describes. Do I get pod dash
o yaml and and take a look at
the definition?
I'm
gonna be honest. I don't remember what the
last break in that fail is.
Get get pod yaml?
Get pod, the name of the pod. So
just copy and paste the clustered one in
and then do a dash o YAML, which
will output the spec.
And a great tip from the audience there
as well. Alias and cube control to key
is a good time saver.
Yeah.
Really? I need to start upgrading these clusters
to one two one so we don't go
to managed fields.
Let
us see.
Oh, okay. You broke it yourselves. That wasn't
me.
The CPU should be 1,000. Yeah.
It wasn't me. Good.
I I couldn't remember what the other break
was there. Yeah. You just wanted to keep
control head on that.
Who's got the the keys?
That was Tom most recently. Okay.
Oh, it's your turn, Jeremy. Sorry. I'll stop
talking to you. Go ahead.
Hands off.
Alright. We're almost there. Come on, team.
We wanted our kube control edit deployment clustered.
Is is someone firing keystrokes in there?
But I'm judging by Tom's laughter. Yes.
You can't trip me while I'm while I'm
crawling.
And while we're in here, let's fix one
more thing that I don't think we we
need to worry about, but let's search for
policy.
I did modify the image pool policy.
Maybe Jason will be so kind just to
tell us why that was such a stupid
thing to say.
Yeah. So the image pool policy,
basically,
you know, it it depends on how you're
validating and deploying your containers that you wanna
use in the environments.
So right now, that one being set to
never means that,
basically, it will never try to pull down
the pod onto the host as part of
bringing up that
that pod. It'll expect that that container has
already been pulled
onto the host by some other
process.
Generally,
you want it to set at least to,
if not present, so that when the pod
is scheduled,
it'll,
you know, pull that container
image
if it isn't already on the host.
In some cases, some people set it to
always,
but
that has some other implications too. Because if
you're relying on the behavior of always, that
means you're modifying
the tags that you're using for images,
and
that could lead to
other potential issues there too. So
it
doesn't really matter what we set it to
for this case.
But Go up, Jeremy.
Which line? CPU one. Two more. Yeah. CPU
is one down two. Down three. Right there.
It should be 1,000. So one CPU actually
means one millicore of a CPU.
But I'm surprised that's a string.
Is that supposed to be a string?
There's
a few fields in Kubernetes
that are defined as int or string,
and will take either an integer or a
string as content.
So I expect that's probably what we're dealing
with here for the CPU limits.
Alright. So that should assuming your container gets
scheduled on the original
node where the image is pulled, you should
be okay.
And it's pending. So you we got really
unlucky there, and you're gonna have to modify
the image pull policy, I'm afraid.
Yep.
Where's that? Just Oh, did it. Same file?
Yeah.
So you you can just search for never
here,
and for simplicity, just replace it with always.
With a capital m.
Yep.
Are you on your ERCODOX today, Jeremy?
Yes.
That's not does that
what jumps me there? That jumps me there.
Right.
So always and have not present. Always is
probably easier for now.
Perfect.
Okay. There's one more thing, another to fix
our application.
And
hopefully, just pulling on a new node
should be harmless.
You can do it watch again if you
want.
I dropped the dash a here because
just getting things in the default namespace will
make the output a little bit clearer.
Handing is what I need to be honest.
Mind if I type for a second?
Go for it.
Is that breaking the rules? Are we allowed
to do that? Well, I mean, it's not
a break that I brought, so I think
it's alright.
Okay.
And there's me using my alias. Sorry.
So I think I Oh, insufficient CPU.
One k?
There we go.
So that I think that was that string
conversion thing and then goes change it to
one
k. It must be using like string string
to y or whatever that function is.
So
the 100 m just as explicitly say one
one CPU, 1,000 milli cores. That's weird. I've
never I've never seen that before.
Me now, you're all teaching me stuff as
well. That's awesome.
Hey, you got your pod back. You want
me to do a port forward? Can we
check, see if it's working? Of course.
Get pods.
This one.
Okay.
Now it's complaining, and I'm sure we'll get
a time out and hopefully just a few
seconds, but I can't
reach the postcard service.
You'll need to do both of that.
It's the last thing, I swear.
Well, so if it can't reach the Postgres
service,
you know, some of the things that we
can look at are,
you know, how's it trying to reach a
Postgres service? How's the application configured to talk
to the database?
And
based on that,
we may need to look at the actual
service that's fronting
the stateful set if there is one.
I think that's a good idea.
Yeah.
That was subtle.
So we can go ahead and just do
a kubectl get services here and see what's
defined as far as services.
Who's up now?
Jeremy. Yeah. Jeremy, go on. I
may need to refresh my
refresh my teleport. You should hear you should
hear banging clicking. Alright. Tom, you're up. And
no Alright.
So cube control get SVC
or get services. Oh, woah. Woah. What just
happened?
I could see. To reload sometimes when someone
joins it. I guess a low can Yeah.
Okay.
I could see it, but not control it.
Secure Cube control mode. I like it.
SVC. The cuddles. SVC.
Okay. There we go. Cubic
TLS.
Yeah.
So we do have a Postgres service. I'll
let
Jason get It is running.
Yep.
We can go ahead and I'm
I'm curious, Jason. Do mind if I jump
in for a second? Yep. Like, based on
all of the kube control stuff we've been
doing so far, Jeremy and Tom. Right?
We've done a get service. What do you
think's next?
Probably describe that service. Describe that service? Good
call. I was just curious if, you know,
hopefully things were were landing there. If
at the
there's said jumping in too. Describe it.
One of the other things I was gonna
say too is a lot of the commands
also have a wide mode. So if you
do like a dash o wide, sometimes,
you know, it'll give you more detail on
that GET as well. Yeah. That's a great
tip too.
You should do that as well.
Like the kubectl thing,
as you know, it's
a rest like client get, describe,
edit. These things are just the staples of
all Kubernetes interactions, at least through a kube
control, anyway.
So what's wrong with that? It's get service
dash o wait. Yeah. It works for the
get, not for describe. Gotcha. And you guys
need to describe.
Delete describe.
Yes. Yes. Yes.
Okay.
Boom. Okay.
Alright.
So
let's see. Looking at that Postgres service,
we can see that it's
a type of cluster IP. That makes sense.
We have an app equals Postgres for the
selector.
It has an IP.
And
if we look at the port
And this is
where it's been a while since I dealt
with Postgres.
I don't quite remember if it listens on
TCP.
It's supposed to listen on TCP in addition
to UDP or if it's just a UDP
service. Good catch.
So we need both? No. TCP.
Just TCP. Okay.
Yep. So
Edit.
And then it's
s s you go at the resource tab
first. Edit the service.
Here we go.
Protocol.
Go down.
Alright. You're almost there.
You'll probably wanna describe your service again
with a a dash of weight.
So this is the output that's the most
important.
Alright. And if you look at that service
above the Kubernetes service, you can see that
there are some endpoints defined for that one.
And we're don't have any endpoints currently for
the Postgres service.
And and the way that the service maps
pods is it actually looks for
that label selector that's defined. So in this
case, app equals Postgres.
So one of the things we can do,
we can look look at that Postgres stateful
set and see
to make sure that it has that
that label actually set on it.
But we don't so since that's not set,
no endpoints
from Noel.
No. Well, yeah, the only thing you know
right now is there's no endpoints, and Jason
has given you some great advice that endpoints
are connected to selectors.
So we probably wanna check
that this selector exists on our deployment, The
app equals Postgres.
So if you describe our cluster deployment
yeah. They already answered it. They're jumping in
with the endpoints and label check too. Because
I think that's based everybody at some point.
Right?
Oh, yeah.
Deployment
custard.
Yeah.
I'd have to consider calling to see these
custards, but it wasn't as catchy.
Alright.
So you The
important part here is what we're gonna wanna
look at is the actual pod template, not
necessarily the labels on the deployment itself.
So underneath the pod template
actually, this is the clustered
deployment. We wanna look at the Postgres deployment.
Oh, sorry. Not deployment. Stateful set.
Yep. So if we look at that pod
template,
labels
app equals PostgresQL,
And I think the service was for Postgres,
not for PostgresQL.
Ah,
Postgres.
Clumsy fingers. Sorry, y'all.
I I I don't believe you're sorry.
Sorry is So
Sorry is the cover of box. And you
would do you would do it again.
Does it matter, Jason, which one we change?
So
it shouldn't
matter.
The the one thing,
the stateful set,
I don't think a stateful set define. Does
it have a label selector for the
pods that it manages?
I do not Yeah. I would edit the
service just in case. It's it's more like
Yeah.
I think even potentially
the template labels as well are immutable on
deployments and stateful sets. I don't even remember
if those can can be changed.
You want No. No. Close. You don't need
deployment there. You just want the service.
The service is called Postgres.
Yeah. That was the I've the I've got
the typo there
and an extra space. Let's edit that,
and let's find our label.
And it's actually the
selector.
Oh, selector right there. Okay. See it.
Postgres. Let's change that to q l.
Just go back.
You wanna describe that service
again. Yep.
There should be an l in Cuddle.
Yep.
I'm gonna add documentation and and a code
of conduct for the show where you have
to pronounce the cube controller. You're not invited
back. I'm just I'm just Alright.
So now we do have endpoints.
Good job. So assuming the application is test
it? Configured correctly to talk to the service,
it should be able to. Ta da.
That's it.
He was just like, random box. I keep
meaning to re encode it. But we're getting
we are getting our wonderful cloud native quotes
at the top of our service. So
it's all good.
It's working. Good job. Fair enough there.
Yay. Awesome
work. I need a nap.
I'm
just glad for this time I wasn't having
to type live on air.
Come fix a cluster they said. It'll be
fun
they said.
Well, I mean, let's let's focus on right.
Did you did you learn a little Kubernetes
today?
Yes. I hope that's coming through. I think
a lot of these breaks are things that
just happened day in and day out in
Kubernetes. So easy to make labels selectors being
wrong, ports being mismatched,
protocol and just,
you know, really simple things that can really
trip people up.
You know, I hope this helped build a
little bit of familiarity with kubectl.
Jason does a great job of guiding you
through all of that. And I think you
both answered both asked a lot of really
good questions throughout that as well. And and
hopefully we just provide some really good fundamental
Kubernetes knowledge. So thank you for joining me
all today. I really enjoyed
watching you suffer a little bit, but
also Was was glad was
glad to be here and also
easily illustrates the use of a second set
of eyes even if you don't know what
the problem is. The
the frequently phone a friend is a
and bounce something off instead of bang your
head on it by yourself.
I am now only referring to this
sadism with David.
Well, I'm gonna move the comments so I
stop getting my eyes covered up.
So no. That was fun. Thanks for having
me. That was a lot of fun. Nerve
racking, but it's so much fun. And, Jason,
thank you for joining us. This would have
been a
six hours later, we'd still be
I'd still be where I where I was
when I started, so thank you for your
help.
Absolutely.
Alright. Thanks for having me. Thank you, everybody.
Have a wonderful day. We'll see you all
next week. Thanks. Bye all.